welcome to this video coverage of round
two of my tournament played in bad vc
Bavaria Germany yeah the second round of
a Swiss system tournament usually brings
somewhat higher rated opponent than the
first one in case you have won the game
and this is no exception the second
round my opponent was Hans bethe Rutte
ich möchte ich he's rated 2081
so a little bit more than 130 points
higher than my first round opponent yeah
it's a color switch I've got the white
pieces in this game and this was the the
first game actually where some
preparation was possible
I am had a look at his games and I
noticed that he placed the Dutch defense
all the time against before he played a
sharp sicilians which pretty much ruled
out any idea of me playing efore as a
surprise I don't really want any super
sharp stuff then um and against
defoliate the Dutch so okay I was
thinking what to do against the Dutch
and I was looking for some sidelines
that is yeah this is having some bite
but it's not so well known it at the end
I came up with the following there five
and I went 93 yeah one idea of those
sidelines is that very often black does
not get to play his desired setup in in
the case of my opponent he is Leningrad
Dutch player so he likes to play a set
up based on g6 and after Knight c3 g6
base setup is hard to achieve Knight f6
was played now I was threatening efore
so if black is not reacting in any way
and play in a known place that I'm going
to go before and open up the position to
my advantage
yeah he went Knight f6 which is which I
also expected he had like two games with
this
then Bishop g5 is the normal move again
trying to prepare the push e 2 2 e form
he played d5 now yeah this is the the
main Muslim trying to prevent a form and
not just trying this move is prevented
now but what I do like about the setup
is that it's a slight psychological
victory for white as there is no
Leningrad type of play with d6g 6 + e5
anymore
this dark squared can of strategy is
gone and now we have something that
looks more like a stone wall with d5 and
f5 this is not super great for white but
it's a position type that I hope that my
opponent is not that familiar with here
White has two principle choices he can
take on f6 and then go III or white can
play III immediately to be honest I'm
not such a huge fan about of this line
the capture on f6 line because as I feel
that like has a pretty decent game he
can't very often put his pieces like
that and cancel long and I'm not totally
sure what White's plan is sometimes you
can play with a3 before I put something
on c5 yeah there are ideas but I don't
like it that much in my preparation I've
found that there's also the movie 3
which is less known but not bad after e3
he went ecigs
and I just play Knight f3 so I'm just
playing normal developing development
moves
the only drawback of course of whites
position is that I have an ID on c3
this does not look right but it is not
not that terrible actually
he went Bishop e7 he M yeah maybe you
can argue that the move C hive
immediately is is more interesting the
point is
or one fact is that he played c5 in the
game just one later and then after my
capture he had to take two moves to
captured c5 and here the possible
capture on c5 could be answered with the
recapture in one move
okay I want to take on c5 I guess but
yes if I was interesting one way to play
is Bishop b5 check then what we
shouldn't underestimate by right having
omitted the muth C form we have somewhat
better developed is white which
sometimes can lead to interesting play
for example if black plays Bishop d7
here the capture is quite interesting as
after Queen takes ninety five sets
immediate problems yeah there are ideas
like this and the double capture on d7
which would yeah bring the black King
out this for example was played in a
number of games and why didn't didn't
fare so badly but I must admit that my
preparation basically ended here I was
just thinking okay I'm getting him to a
position that is not so familiar with
and then we just play play chess yeah he
went Bishop e7 I went Bishop two three
and he played c5 yeah of course I had
seen this idea in my preparation my prep
basically consisted of just playing
through some games and this was
something that I noted on noticed that
after c5 White has a good option in
capturing ya know castles 96 and then
Knight a for this was a maneuver that I
am yeah I found quite remarkable and I
had basically yeah memorized for the
game that this is something that I
should do if the opportunity is is
coming up
he went to e7 now and that plays c4
that's the idea with Knight a for and c4
I'm getting the C pawn into play and get
some pressure on d5 this is intensified
like that yeah so what is this there
this is a little bit like a
gambits the whole structure with Bishop
on g5 and c4 bishop on d3 the only real
thing is black has played f5 yeah if he
in this position could play f5 back to
f7 his position would be super solid
really nothing happening at all but
that's not the case the pawn is on f5
and this means that the center is a
little bit weakened it's nothing
terrible but he always has to worry that
he has got he gets some problems on with
his central pawns for example if he
plays a move like aged six I can take
and play something like that and we see
the problems that come with the F pawn
push just one one possible line that can
can arise he didn't play age six he
played the move Knight to e4 yeah Knight
to e4 instead yeah after that I think
White has a slight advantage which
probably is a fair assessment of the of
the whole variation here why does a
little bit better I captured now on e7
he took with the Queen yeah and in this
in this position
I took a longer thing like 15 minutes or
so which is a little bit uncommon for me
I tend to play really quickly in
tournament chess um yeah the thing is I
I took some time because well I
recognized that C takes d5 is certainly
a little bit better for me but I
wondered if I maybe have some other idea
this after C takes Knight takes B takes
pawn takes and now let's say Queen b3
who should be 694 it's a little bit
better for me but I wasn't totally
satisfied with that I was thinking okay
is there some other idea that that is
possible here white is a little bit
better because well this is a bit weak
this is a bit weak the bishop on e6 is
not great so a slight edge for white
but well I was looking at Eid
alternatives in this position and then I
recognized the move that I liked and
yeah it turns out that my calculation
what I was seeing wasn't totally spot-on
but I still like the idea I played to
move Queen to b1 which is not very
obvious in a way but it is it has some
interesting points one idea is that the
queen is x-raying the b-pawn sounds
weird but there is some point to it
for example if black plays now let's say
I move like Bishop d7 are just
developing then I take and after Knight
takes B takes Knight takes this hangs
this is an idea of the Queen being on b1
or alternatively if black plays a move
like yeah like b6 for example I have
this kind of idea the Queen can be
activated and used against those loose
pieces of pawns it turns out that the
move is not really that great it could
be one I think the simple CD 5 was
better but it's still interesting and
sometimes I mean you you can always play
the standard moves but if you are
attracted by an interesting solution why
not this and the move also has
additional ideas and we see this now
black now played not this move but he
took on c3 and he took on c4 and now we
see another idea of the the coup the
Queen here I'm intending to go here and
play a form you know this is in fact
happening in the game he played Knight
a5 that seems to be okay Bishop b3 and
now he played a very committal move and
this is a line that I had seen
when I played Queen Bee one that the
movie 5 now is slightly questionable but
this is what he played um if you were
analyzed this year with the computer the
computer will just play the move p6 and
this is something that I did not really
I did not really assess correctly in the
game I was thinking that after b6 e form
I should be better one idea of the Queen
and Bishop configuration it's clear that
black of course cannot take this is a
very simple double attack but like can't
in fact just go here and this is quite
ok for him you know I didn't did not
really appreciate that um the problem is
that capture here when f5 is far less
effective because while he can take it
no and I mean there are even very young
embarrassing lines like that available
which means that I cannot take and I
will probably play move like maybe
ninety for him after which the computer
just quite yeah very simply play plays
g6m and it seems that I don't have
anything right I mean white is not words
or anything but it's it's probably just
about equal in the in the alternative
line with the earlier earlier C takes d5
I think white has a stable slide edge so
this is probably the the reason why my
continuation with Queen b1 isn't that
great however he played 'if I've this is
what I had anticipated and in fact after
that I think white has a little bit of
an advantage it's not great this edge
but it is a bit more comfortable for
white the reason is the following
efore and well it's clear that now black
should not take this just leads to a
great position for
I have this pressure with this fantastic
bishop and there is additional pressure
put on e5 so black basically has to play
a four there is no choice and now Queen
b5 is coming
an additional point of the Queen B one
idea yeah
Hanks Hanks okay we have to go back and
now look a b1 this is what I had
envisioned earlier I have the B file I
have pressure against a5 and I have this
additional idea which intensifies the
pressure however it seems that black is
not in such a terrible shape if he has
precise
for example the move rook b8 e and this
position would have led to a decent
position for black after the check and
Bishop g5 during the game of thinking
that this should be better for white
because bishop takes his six as a
serious threat however it's not that
much of a problem black can't really
play just this move because after this
he has rook be to e8 surprisingly yeah I
mean the capture is not that good
because he I always has to reckon with
this ad with this kind of ideas yeah or
a Brooke before that same and then the
move but rook beat we ate surprisingly
strong as I really have very little
prospects to keep my pawns there are
those those pawns are really weak and
the bishop is much stronger than the
night
it seems that black has no problems here
whatsoever so there are interesting
defensive resources the position is less
convincing for white then I then have
thought but he didn't play rook b8 he
played rook to f6 and which is not bad
probably but I think what what he tried
to do is really to get an attack on my
king something like rook over and then
pushed the pawn him and this is frankly
speaking not very realistic um the rook
has some counter play value on the 6th
rank but it's
it's very tough to get a real attack
going I simply have too much pressure in
the center and on the queenside okay I
went with the check and Bishop g5 as
planned and yeah the situation got got a
little bit critical now who black also
because I had a huge advantage on the
clock this is a typical situation that I
had in the whole tournament I usually
was fired on the clock because I tend to
play play quickly in tournament chess
and I have I'm not really much of a
perfectionist ever I think that I have a
good move and usually play it and don't
look for a very long time for the best
move yeah
what is the idea simply to take and take
a five black really it does not have
much choice he has to play a six and now
I drop back to B - yeah why - B - I
wanted to go to b6 I mean I would have
liked to go there but then he has this
discovered motif on the Queen so no way
I can go to b6 I have to go to B - not a
bad square the reason is that it looks
at the e5 pawn so one possible idea is
to push c4 and then maybe win the e5
pawn yeah he played the move rook g6
which is fairly logical after he went
through f6 and I don't think I have
anything better than King to h1 this is
I think a good move and have played it
rather quickly I need to get out of this
Bishop h3 ideas and here we have the
decisive position of the game as
mentioned he was already a little bit in
slider time pressure and yeah here black
definitely needs to play a defensive
move he has to prepare the bishop move
from c8 as long as I have this pressure
on the b7 pawn he can cannot ever
develop
the bishop so I think the move that he
should play is rook b8 and after rook b8
for example it it might continue along
these lines maybe Age 3 that's not so
easy this decision because it might
allow the bishop to sacrifice itself but
I still think I should prevent Bishop to
g4 yeah now for example Bishop d7
Luke t1 Brooke h6 rook t3 something like
that is a logical continuation and here
white is a little bit better but it's
nothing totally clear or or decisive so
he can definitely fight on it's nothing
serious for white however he played
really really hard to explain move I
think he said that he just confused to
move order and he played the move Queen
to d7 which really shocked me because I
was thinking okay I can't just take c6
and and what what exactly is the problem
I was a little bit little stunned here
because what I thought oh what did I
overlook here yeah in fact I didn't
overlook anything white can just take on
c6 and now Knight takes d5 is coming and
this was basically just a blunder he was
banking on the fact that he has a
counter threat here but I can just play
rook g1 and I'm covering everything
there is really no no attack whatsoever
yeah he now tried to move look to edge
sorry this was the wrong button the
moves look to h6 yeah he simply has no
move whatever way he takes I'm going to
to walk him and there is no attack after
the rook is falling on g6 yeah he hits
right the relatively the best relatively
best movie played rook h6 and it's lost
anyway but here at least I can I can
play a play a terrible mistake after
this move I'm going to get checkmate it
so it's not too late to hit you to play
stupid stuff and kill yourself
yeah in fact if we look at this I have a
very safe Kingdom the night is always
protecting edge to the rookies
protecting g2 and there is nothing
serious going on I can simply take on b7
him and when this pawn had in this in
the same moment trade off pieces yeah he
went rook b8
and I can even just play Bishop take c8
because of the counter-attack on the
Queen the moves rook takes B - it's no
problem at all with white being two
pieces up so after Bishop c8 he played
rook c8 and I continued with c4 yeah of
course he can resign basically but he
didn't have much time and just played to
play it on for a couple of moves
he went rook h3 funny move I can't I
can't take it yeah there is no reason
not to but I can just take e5 as well
intending the route move to b8 I had
seen the line up to the the end of the
game and I was hoping that it it appears
on the board and it did he took him
check rook g2 and now he played rook e8
black is a pawn down but he he also saw
the the nice point now but he wanted to
play it out because it looks nice Queen
takes g7 check and he resigned facing
made after fp8 and rook takes g8 mate so
escort the second win in in round 2 very
important to keep close to them
yeah to the pack of leaders if we go
back let's have a quick recap yeah we
had this slightly offbeat line in
the Dutch it seems that after his set up
here with 94 the move C takes d5 gives
white a slight edge but I've held
attracted to this idea of playing Queen
to be one I still like it I mean it's
probably the second best move our third
best move in the position but still I
like the idea it's a it's an interesting
interesting way to play yeah after this
it seems that b6 was a good way for
black to play but he went in five and I
think after that white is a little bit
better but it is not a clear a clear
fair as we had seen if he here improves
with with rook b8 the whole situation
stays very murky he still has some kind
of counter play here on the Kings side
and I'm not winning quickly on the Queen
side or anything so something that
really needs to be played out with with
an unclear unclear outcome in a way yeah
okay I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
this game and maybe you can use this
line against the Dutch in your games if
you look at for our non theoretical line
against the Dutch then this setup is
very nicely in playable it so not much
work at all to memorize if you know this
game and maybe a couple of others you
can easily play it and it's it's
something that um that will very often
get black out of his normal comfort zone
because you don't get to play a g6 setup
yeah I hope you liked it thanks for
watching